SCP-682 Vs a Fighter Jet: Who would win?
Well, that depends on your definition of “win.”
In terms of short-term immobilization required
for getting 682 recontained, a fighter jet
would likely be an asset to any MTF hoping
to get 682 back under control, given its high
speed and weapons capable of at least effectively
stalling the monster.
However, if we’re talking “to the death”
then we’ll have to consider that missiles
and conventional arms fire have no lasting
effect against 682.
Given enough time, it would adapt to either
fly or fling projectiles capable of taking
the jet down or BOTH?!
Imagine a flying, missile-launching 682?
WOW that’s absolutely terrifying.
SCP-682 vs an M1 Abrams Tank: Who would win?
While the M1 Abrams is an enduring piece of
military technology with strong offensive
and defensive capabilities, is there actually
a contest to be had here?
682 has survived everything from the Shy Guy
to the Gate Guardian.
The only thing that a tank would offer is
a slightly longer time spent unboxing 682’s
meal - That being, the unfortunate operatives
running the tank.
The moral of today’s short?
Don’t bring a tank to an immortal anomaly
fight.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-106.
Reptile Vs Old Man.
The most hateful SCP Vs The Most Sadistic.
Who would win?
This is another one we have precedent for.
These two engaged in a three-way battle with
SCP-953, the polymorphic humanoid, during
a containment breach.
All three were pulled into 106’s pocket
dimension, and the battle took place there.
Both returned from the pocket dimension, heavily
injured, and were either easily subdued or
returned organically to their containment
chambers.
It was a draw.
We can’t imagine either of them would be
eager for a rematch any time soon.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-053.
What happens when you pit the Hard to Destroy
Reptile against a very lonely, very deadly
little girl?
This Foundation cross-test allowed us to find
out.
053 has the power to turn people into violent
maniacs, who then immediately die when they
try to attack her.
Researchers hoped the same thing would happen
to SCP-682.
In fact, the absolute opposite happened.
053 seemed to be one of the only creatures
in the universe that 682 becomes totally docile
around.
And despite 053’s initial fear of the beast,
she soon plucked up the courage to approach
and make a friend.
The two played together, with 682 even allowing
053 to draw on its face.
Both became distressed when the two separated.
053 began to cry, and 682 went berserk and
started killing people.
Sadly for both of them, the Foundation has
deemed shared containment to be too much of
a risk to ever be allowed.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-662.
Can the world’s greatest butler transfer
his skills into being the world’s best monster
slayer, and finally bring an end to SCP-682?
When asked to kill the beast, he apologized
profusely and stated that he couldn’t do
it.
He could perhaps distract 682 by sacrificing
himself to it, at least.
As the Foundation persisted
with their questioning,
Mr. Deeds made an alternate suggestion: Perhaps
if his body was laced with a powerful toxin
or booby-trapped with explosives, then fed
to SCP-682, he could do more damage.
Mr. Deeds was dismissed shortly thereafter.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-061.
Could a mind-controlling music program finally
be the key to destroying the infamous Hard
to Destroy Reptile?
682 entered the relaxed state typical of people
undergoing 061 hypnosis at
first, as the Foundation
gave a number of menial orders, such as rolling
over.
682 clearly tried to resist, even entering
a violent seizure.
When ordered to “stand up”, it suddenly
became immune to 061’s powers, carrying
out a violent assault on the staff and breaching
containment.
It appeared to somehow integrate the abilities
of 061 into its own biology, releasing a screech
that stunned everyone nearby, and allowing
it to devour several people before it was
recontained.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-524.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile Vs The cuddly
wittle bunny named Walter that can eat pretty
much everything.
Does 682 look enough like a big, angry carrot
for Walter to get the job done?
682 regarded Walter with suspicion as the
bunny approached.
It then began gnawing through 682’s leg,
causing the giant monster to bellow and flee.
He chased 682 around the containment chamber
for several minutes, before 682 tapped out.
682 climbed up the wall of the test chamber
and waited, while Walter washed his face with
his paws. 524 then began chewing his way through
the wall of the test chamber, at which point,
the experiment was aborted.
Still, very good try, little buddy.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-513.
Sometimes, to take down a scary SCP like SCP-682,
you need to bring in an even scarier SCP,
like this demonic cowbell and the phantom
it reveals.
SCP-682 was partially incinerated and brought
into a testing chamber, where a robot arm
rang the SCP-513 bell several times, with
the resulting sound causing extreme stress
for SCP-682.
Aerosolized tranquilizers and sedatives were
pumped into the chamber, causing 682 to fall
unconscious.
It then began sleepwalking, breaching the
containment chamber, but it wasn’t alone:
A nightmarish, ghost-like entity, resembling
SCP-682, began stalking the halls.
After mass hysteria and mass staff death across
the site, the Foundation finally got things
back under control.
When SCP-682 was woken up, it complained,
saying that it was having such a lovely dream...
SCP-2305-A: An anomalous document that manifests
methods of neutralizing various SCPs, all
of which are doomed to fail.
So what did it have to say about SCP-682?
To make a very long and elaborate story short,
through a mix of anomalies and massive hydrogen
bombs, SCP-682 would be transported to the
moon and blown to smithereens in a massive,
ridiculous explosion.
Earth is pounded by the resulting meteors
from the explosion.
While only a tiny quantity of 682’s blood
survived the bombardment, it managed to regenerate
and adapt.
It became the size of Saturn and ended up
eating our solar system.
The moral of the story: Don’t redacted with
this gecko.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-2521.
An unspeakably cruel and violent reptile Vs
a monster that is literally unspeakable.
Who won?
Let’s find out.
The Foundation used a laser cutting tool to
etch information about SCP-2521 into the skin
of SCP-682’s side, in the hopes that the
monster would turn up and steal SCP-682.
However, it didn’t work out that way.
Instead, it just appeared and tore the skin
off of 682’s side before demanifesting.
682 regenerated the missing skin later.
Better luck next time.
Oh, come on!
Every time!
SCP-682 Vs SCP-811.
Could the sweet, misunderstood Swamp Woman
finally end the wretched life of the Hard
to Destroy Reptile?
Let’s find out.
In a rare act of cross-test kindness, the
Foundation refused to pit 811 against 682
directly, due to the justifiable fear that
it would simply murder the Swamp Woman.
However, the Swamp Woman’s deadly, corrosive
mucus was harvested and applied to 682’s
skin.
The fizzling muck was able to reduce 682’s
body mass by 27%, until the creature evolved
a complete bone covering of the remaining
body mass, rendering the mucus ineffective.
But hey, at least this didn’t cause any
undue stress to SCP-811.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-2578-D.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile would kill millions
if ever it was allowed to escape and be free.
Would the SCP-2578-D Impaler spacecraft be
able to put its reign of terror to an end?
SCP-2578-D is a mysterious spacecraft with
an immensely powerful and precise proton cannon.
It seeks to protect democracy and human rights
from tyrants, fascists, and authoritarians
through controlled assassinations, or “Impaler
Events.”
One such event befell 682 in containment,
with five cranial penetrative wounds that
pierced its skull during a brief period, leaving
it out of commission for 32 minutes.
It then woke back up and yelled “F YOU AND
ALL THREE OF YOUR MOONS!”
up to the ceiling.
The spacecraft later sent an email to the
Foundation, apologizing that it hadn’t killed
682.
In its defense, though, it hadn’t missed
a single shot.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-2337.
Could the Hard to Destroy Reptile meet its
end at the dangerously booming voice of the
talkative Dr. Spanko?
As part of a tissue test, Dr. Spanko was told
682’s flesh was a tone-deaf food critic
who needed to be convinced on what the greatest
food in existence was.
Spanko argued so loudly that the answer was
gummy worms that it destroyed 682’s flesh.
The next step was sending him in to talk the
actual 682 to death, after being told the
reptile was an “anti-gummy worm extremist.”
This seemed promising until Dr. Spanko confidently
entered the chamber, and 682 simply boomed
“LEAVE”, at which point Dr. Spanko turned,
literally yelled the wall down, and did just
that.
682 must really hate gummy worms.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-2617.
Could the icy operatives of the winter command
finally be the ones to take down the Hard
to Destroy Reptile?
SCP-682 was airlifted into the abandoned Russian
village where the 2617 radio tower was situated,
and the Foundation fed the tower the reptile’s
coordinates as it began attacking the village.
2617 generated a large number of deadly ice
warriors, who took on SCP-682 with both ferocity
and skill, destroying 45% of its body mass
through sustained attacks.
It looked like they might have the lizard
on the ropes…
Until it began putting out its own radio waves,
affecting and disrupting the 2617 radio tower,
as well as the researchers in attendance.
The affected personnel, when later interviewed,
were unable to recognize even the concept
of Russia.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-3930.
Could the patch of nothingness, the true oblivion
in the heart of rural Russia, finally consign
the nightmarish reptile to non-existence?
Let’s see.
The tissue sample from 682 was successfully
destroyed by being placed inside 3930.
But the rest of the reptile would be a little
more complicated.
Its body was placed into the void and ceased
existing.
However, despite ceasing to exist, it could
still be perceived and slaughtered several
of the guards and researchers in attendance.
Thankfully, it did eventually disappear.
Until 15 hours later, when it suddenly manifested
once again in its containment chamber, good
as new.
Of course, nobody really knows how or why.
We just don’t question it at this point.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-1056.
Could this anomalous, body-warping kitchen
timer finally be the thing that shrinks SCP-682
down to size?
Let’s find out.
The objective of the test was to see how long
it would take SCP-682 to return to its normal
size after being resized by SCP-1056.
However, when the creature was meant to be
shrunk to a quarter of its size, it simply
disappeared.
It was later found causing chaos outside of
Site-19, having returned to its normal size.
When a Mobile Task Force was sent to apprehend
682, it released a wave that instead massively
shrunk the task force.
It continued to rampage elsewhere, manipulating
its size at will, until a combined group of
Mobile Task Forces were able to incapacitate
it.
Researchers concluded that it had not only
absorbed the anomalous effect of SCP-1056,
but enhanced it, leading to considerably more
powerful defensive and offensive body-resizing
capabilities.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-3207.
No weapon the Foundation has ever created
has been able to kill SCP-682, so maybe a
crazy anomalous energy cannon created by Leonardo
Davinci and Marco Saul will get the job done.
The tissue test went well, as the energy cannon
was able to completely vaporize the SCP-682
flesh with a single blast.
With this promising result, they went on to
the full test: 3207 appeared to completely
annihilate SCP-682 with a few well-aimed blasts,
leading to a great deal of relief among the
attending researchers…
For a few hours, at least.
Several nasty little creatures regenerated
from the scattered tissue of SCP-682.
When these creatures breached containment,
they fused back into SCP-682.
Because of course they did.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-393.
So many of the Foundation’s plans to kill
SCP-682 have failed, but maybe that’s just
because they never wrote it down in SCP-393,
this singularly unique day planner.
SCP-393 is a day planner that bonds to a nearby
subject, and when they write their plans into
it, they will soon develop a complete memory
of having achieved those plans.
Perhaps this could be used to figure out how
to kill 682.
A D-Class was given the planner, and asked
to write “Going to somehow defeat SCP-682
today.”
The D-Class was later found comatose with
a horrified expression on their face, and
died shortly after.
A defeated note from a young research assistant
on the test file reads, “It was worth a
shot…”
SCP-682 VS An Industrial-Grade Blender Followed
by Strong Centrifuge.
Could this, the most hardcore of industrial
kitchen equipment, finally take down the Hard
to Destroy Reptile?
A 682 tissue sample was reduced into a fine
slurry by the blender and then placed into
the centrifuge, which slowly increased to
a truly insane number of rotations per minute.
And…
The sample exploded, severely injuring twelve
members of personnel and almost killing Dr.
Carlson, one of the lead researchers on the
project.
It turned out that SCP-682’s flesh contains
anti-matter, hence the violent chemical reaction
that transpired.
Naturally, further testing of this matter
was forbidden by the O5 Council, to reduce
the number of unnecessary explosions occurring
on site.
I guess we’ll never truly know the outcome
on this one huh?
SCP-682, the indestructible reptile, versus
SCP-241, “Good Home Cooking”.
What happens when you
introduce the humanity-hating
lizard to a cookbook that sends the person
eating the recipes into anaphylactic shock?
Let’s find out.
A portion of 682’s skin tissue was fixed
to a steel rod, which was held by a D-Class
and used to turn the pages of 241.
The cookbook displayed 99 new recipes, including
three in an unknown language, two that were
completely incomprehensible, and one that
contained a memetic kill agent.
The remaining recipes all contained instructions
that made accurate preparation impossible,
such as “marinate for 900 trillion years”.
D-Class personnel was tasked with preparing
these 93 recipes.
Upon completion, each dish was served directly
to the lizard.
Naturally, it was able to consume all 93 meals
without any difficulty.
For 682, this was most likely one of the more
enjoyable termination attempts.
Bon appétit!
SCP-682, the indestructible reptile, versus
SCP-3519, a dangerous
memetic contagion responsible
for killing nearly the entire population of
the world.
In a certain timeline, SCP-3519 infected global
media to influence the public into believing
that the world would end on March 5th, 2019,
and that self-destruction was a preferable
option.
Weeks before March 5th, a group of Foundation
personnel decided to test 3519’s exposure
with 682, in hopes that it may terminate the
lizard once and for all.
Lowering the acid levels inside its tank,
682 was exposed to the contagion, but did
not show any self-destructive ideation.
Instead, 682 nightmarishly laughed for 193
seconds before it was placed
back into containment.
After March 5th, there was only one lone human
survivor, Junior Researcher Dr. Rory Jones.
When 682 encountered the Doctor after breaching
containment, it did not kill him.
Instead, it simply stated:
“We are alike now, meat.
Killing you would only end suffering"
SCP-682, the indestructible reptile, versus
SCP-1237, the epsilon wave, who would win?
In an attempt to terminate SCP-682, the Foundation
gave us the answer.
SCP-1237 is a brain pattern occurring in deep
REM sleep that allows an individual's dreams
to shape and affect reality when they wake.
One specimen affected by SCP-1237 was permitted
to observe SCP-682 and was instructed to dream
that SCP-682 was a small house cat with no
anomalous abilities, and that the Foundation
had successfully terminated it.
Seven seconds into their sleep, the subject
seized violently and died less than a minute
later, alongside 13 other observing security
personnel.
Their bodies were covered with scratches and
bites, as well as symptoms of toxoplasmosis
and bubonic plague.
Inside SCP-682’s chamber was a small house
cat, licking blood from its coat of fur.
It regenerated into SCP-682 only a few hours
later.
Looks like in this matchup, the lizard, not
the cat, got the foundation’s tongue, as
expected.
SCP-682 Vs a Vacuum.
And we’re not talking about the household
cleaning appliance.
Could the Hard to Destroy Reptile survive
in a completely air-free environment?
To find out, 99% of the oxygen was removed
from a testing chamber that SCP-682 was trapped
inside.
The creature entered a dormant state, and
began producing what the Foundation believed
to be its native atmosphere - A mixture of
56% ozone, 23% chlorine, 18% xenon, and other
caustic elements.
The test was eventually called to an end,
however, when our normal earth atmosphere
was reintroduced into the room, it reacted
with the compound that 682 was releasing,
and caused a massive explosion that blew off
the blast door.
A scientist remarked that it was no wonder
682 was so hardy if that poisonous mix was
its native atmosphere.
SCP-682 Vs Y-909.
Can the compound derived from SCP-3000, the
legendary Ananatashesha, be the thing that
finally ends the wretched life of SCP-682?
Y-909 is the key ingredient in Foundation
amnestics, and the researchers discovered
a curious thing when it was added to 682’s
tank: It caused an increase in the damage
that hydrochloric acid did to the creature’s
body.
This suggested that 682’s regenerative abilities
are somehow tied to its memories of previous
damage taken.
Some researchers proposed taking SCP-682 directly
to SCP-3000, to see if the giant eel could
kill 682 once and for all.
However, this proposal was soundly rejected,
due to too many unpredictable factors: From
the risk of transporting 682, to its unpredictable
adaptive response to SCP-3000, such as it
possibly growing to SCP-3000’s insane size
or stealing its amnestic abilities.